you gave up drinking about a year and a
half ago yes and you said it was the
hardest thing you ever did yes and I
wanted to know what was so hard about it
for you why was it so hard and I decided
to just give up for January I just
wanted to do dry January and all I could
think about was having a drink all I
could think about I was waking up
thinking about it I was checking the
clock when's it 12 and it just really
scared me I just was like wow maybe
maybe I have a little bit of an alcohol
thing so I sort of decided to punish
myself and say I'll do February as well
I'll do two months off if I can do two
months off then I can prove to myself I
don't have a problem two months go by
and I was still really struggling I felt
like I couldn't be social I felt like I
couldn't go to the pub and have a lime
soda I couldn't go out for dinner I was
really really struggling and I started
to really worry that maybe I had an
alcohol problem
um so I decided that I would wait until
my birthday which is June 1st I said to
myself if I can do six months without
alcohol then I can prove to myself that
I don't have a problem